this final trailer opens with Barry
Allen getting recognized by fans these
kids are covered in Flash pins and it
happens to be in front of a bilby's cafe
which might be a reference to the
character named Bilby in The Time
Machine by H.G Wells really the first
fictional work that you could say
popularized the concept of time travel
and judged by that flag on the door
Philly has made his Cafe a safe space
Jeremy Irons returns as the DC EU Alfred
pennyworth and Bruce Wayne's Hangar on
Alfred screens is a schematic of
Batman's motorcycle with a map of the
city in front of him so basically
Alfred's running point on whatever this
Chase mission that Batman's involved
with and Gotham that he needs Barry's
help with
[Music]